Excuse
me, leave it at that. It's like you
can't see if you're insulting us.
Apologize to Mr. Lum, you guys, leave it at that. Why do you
question? You guys, hey, you guys ca
n't see these clothes.
You idiots.  I'm pretty sure it's the Lotzgard Academy
uniform.If it's a friend, I
'd definitely kill Waka-sama.If
that's the case, is it okay to kill Waka-sama?I like it.Do you think I'm an
idiot? Or could you say Waka-sama?It's killing everyone.Wait, I won't kill you all of a sudden.I see, it's the
biggest thing.  After inflicting pain on her, I
understand that you persuaded her and asked her to take her back. She's scared. I have something to
say to this woman. Don't
get in the way. You guys, I won't kill you.  Don't
drink too much.It's the wind magic that watches over us from the heavens.It's an
attribute that I can't use.But
why did it float?The hand is low, and I'm
surprised at the Wealth Technique.The young master was also shown that that attack was floating.  It's
quite exciting. It definitely
belongs to a different soil. Follow me
[Music]
Reply
Ah
OG